non je voudrais vous accueillir ici chez
vous au républicain nicolas sarkozy va
venir il était en train de discuter avec
des personnes qui ont parrainé beaucoup
de beaucoup de militants
brigitte kuster philippe goujon sont ici
et je les en remercie également
régulièrement en reçoit dans les locaux
de la rue de vaugirard
et c'est pas toujours très simple pour
vous de vous déplacer
mais on souhaite recevoir les militants
les nouveaux militants les personnes qui
adhèrent et les adhésions marche bien en
ce moment et on peut s'en réjouir les je
pense que monsieur nicolas nicolas ne
boudera pas son plaisir de vous donner
les chiffres mais ça montre que les
partis politiques ont encore beaucoup
d'avenir
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire et
qu' il n'y a pas de démocratie sans
parti politique comme n'y a pas
d'économie sans entreprise
après il ya des hauts il ya des buy a
dévoilé un parti politique c'est
simplement des gens qui s'organisent
ensemble autour de leurs convictions et
qui tente de mettre ses convictions en
application au travers d'un truc
absolument ringard qui s'appelle les
élections c'est à dire le fait que des
gens puissent voter pour d'autres et ça
s'appelle de manière plus prestigieuse
la démocratie et on tient la démocratie
française même si évidemment il faut
inventer parfois de nouvelles manières
de dialoguer avec le citoyen ce qu'on
fait toucher et à tout moment dans nos
collectivités comme sur le plan national
alors les républicains sont en ordre de
marche on a rétabli le parti de main de
maître depuis maintenant plus de plus
d'un an
vous le voyez nous n'avions pas de
projet nous commençons à voir un
véritable projet quelque chose de solide
et quelque chose de précis et je pense
que c'est une attente et je vous en
dirai un mot nous devions nous organiser
pour essayer de sélectionner notre
candidat à l'élection à l'élection
présidentielle comme vous l'avez
remarqué il ya plusieurs candidats à la
candidature
nature vous l'avez remarqué vous l'avez
remarqué wesh moi aussi d'ailleurs moi
aussi donc il ya plusieurs candidats et
c est chez à la limite tant mieux tous
les candidats d'en nommer tous les
candidats arriveront pas au processus
ultime de sélection c'est à dire ne sont
pas définitivement candidat mais chacun
peut à un moment donné voilà montrer un
peu sa fougue ou essayer de se faire un
peu de publicité ce qui est très très
important c'est que le processus de
primaires fonctionne et il fonctionne il
ya une haute autorité
il ya un comité politique de
organisation de la primaire que préside
thierry solère de nous y consacrons tous
pour que la procédure soit la plus
claire et la plus clean aussi pour
qu'eux aussi à la fin de ceux de cette
primaire au mois de novembre et ben
émergent quelqu'un qui portera nos
couleurs à l'élection présidentielle
sans contestation et derrière lesquels
nous nous rangerons tous donc un
prochain projet un processus de
sélection de notre candidat et puis
évidemment ce que nicolas sarkozy a pu
obtenir puisqu'il a fallu beaucoup
bataillé pour obtenir cela et pourtant
c'est quand même le bon sens c'est que
nous ayons investi des candidats aux
élections législatives
avant de commencer le processus de
primaires nous on a besoin de candidats
sur le terrain et on va pas laisser le
front national investir des candidats
tout seul qui pourront se prévaloir de
leur investiture alors que nous on sera
encore en train de se batailler de se
chamailler pour savoir qui sera candidat
donc on doit investir nos candidats pour
les élections législatives parce que le
président élu il aura besoin d'une
majorité solide et pour cette majorité
soit solide il faut évidemment des
candidats qui travaillent sur le terrain
d'ores et déjà et qu'ils puissent se
prévaloir de cette investiture ariani
sortant et puis aussi beaucoup de
beaucoup de circonscriptions n'y a pas
de sortant on était dans une période de
basses eaux en 2012 on a perdu les
élections je vous le rappelle est donc
on a beaucoup de circonscriptions à
conquérir ou reconquérir
on a aussi
beaucoup de nouvelles candidates
investir puisqu'on veut la parité donc
il faut de nouvelles candidates il faut
faire un effort très important pour
rechercher de des candidates
donc tout ça prend du temps notamment
des personnes qui parfois sont moins
connus que d'autres donc on doit leur
donner ces investitures et on le fera
d'ici d'ici l'été le parti aura des
candidats investis pour l'élection
législative donc un projet des primaires
une organisation des primaires
une investiture de nos candidats aux
législatives
c'est évidemment beaucoup de travail en
même temps beaucoup de cohésion et
beaucoup de cohérence les républicains
aujourd'hui ont une forte corps et sans
cohérence nous sommes le premier parti
de france incontestablement et ce
premier parti il a des devoirs et nous
devoir c'est d'être à la hauteur de
l'alternance que nous devons préparer
alors on travaille beaucoup sur le
projet c'est un point majeur et beaucoup
d'entre vous contribuer à ce projet on a
travaillé sur le code du travail on a
travaillé sur l'immigration sur la
sécurité sur l'agriculture sur beaucoup
de sujets de cette nature sur la
fonction publique
comment faire évoluer aujourd'hui la
fonction publique et puis comment
réduire ou comment mieux réformer un
état omnipotent et en même temps plus
j'ai un nip autant moins il est omni
puissant il a des difficultés majeures
aujourd'hui à se faire respecter donc
comment essayer de faire revenir l'état
la prérogative de puissance publique au
coeur de l'autorité dont dont la france
a besoin
et puis sur les deux dernières journées
de travail on a travaillé sur des sujets
qui sont éminemment important évidemment
l'économie
comment faire en sorte de redresser
notre pays sur le plan économique et
social
et puis mercredi dernier on a travaillé
sur l'éducation et sur l'enseignement
supérieur sur tous les sujets nous avons
beaucoup de propositions
je vous engage si vous voulez pas fait à
aller sur le site et à à télécharger les
comptes rendus de
2 les documents d'orientation au fond
avant projet les documents d'orientation
qui sont discutées ici puis validez voté
par les militants et à chaque fois des
dizaines de milliers de militants qui
votent les propositions donc nous devons
absolument les faire connaître et pour
tout vous dire moi je trouve que nous
avons aujourd'hui le projet le plus
abouti et c'est normal et on est les
républicains les républicains ont le
projet le plus le plus abouti et le plus
précis et le plus précis lorsqu'on parle
de fiscalité on vous dit comment quoi
pourquoi lorsqu'on parle de fonction
publique de la même manière on évoque le
statut on évoque les droits et les
devoirs de la fonction publique
lorsqu'on évoque l'éducation nationale
on évoque l'école primaire on évoque
l'enseignement supérieur on dit que
l'élève qui était toujours au centre des
réformes c'est probablement pas la bonne
manière de voir les choses peut-être
faut-il mettre les professeurs
l'enseignement c'est à dire celui qui va
délivrer l'apprentissage celui qui va
transmettre ses connaissances qui doit
être au coeur du système et découle de
sap
beaucoup de propositions nouvelles donc
je vous engage vraiment aller découvrir
car elles vont charpenter toutes ces
propositions elles vont charpenter ce
que nous allons publier d'ici la fin du
mois de juin en tout cas avant les
vacances c'est à dire un vrai un vrai
projet est un projet s'est pas
uniquement des mesures c'est pas
uniquement de dire on va baisser les
dépenses publiques de 100 milliards
d'euros
où on va supprimer l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune ou baisser l'impôt sur le
revenu de 10 % ou de réduire les charges
sociales pour les entreprises c'est plus
que ça ça c'est un programme
ça c'est des mesures qu'on nommait les
unes à côté des autres mais ces mesures
elles doivent vouloir dire quelque chose
elles doivent avoir un sens elles
doivent on doit pouvoir se dire que il
ya une cohérence autour de tout cela qui
fait qu' il ya une idée notre pays une
idée l'avenir de notre pays au travers
de ces de ces mesures concrètes que l'on
propose et les deux vont ensemble
comment avoir la vision du pays dans les
années qui viennent
comment avoir la vision du pays dans
l'europe aujourd'hui qui est
totalement à côté de la plaque par
rapport aux opinions publiques par
rapport à l'opinion française par
rapport presque à nous même maintenant
donc il faut vraiment qu'il ya un coup
de collier un sursaut européen
comment faire en sorte que cette vision
puisse être très clairement illustré par
des propositions très concrètes
souvent nous dit ouais mais est ce que
vous le ferez la plus on dit avant plus
on le fera après - on le dit avant moi
on le fera après vous pourrez vous
méfier des trucs qu'on dit pas là il y
aura peut-être de l'ambiguïté donc il
faudra nous pousse à aller dire
certainement durant cette campagne
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que à
plus d'un an de l'élection
présidentielle
jamais la droite et le centre
enfin le centre c'est le centre droit la
droite jamais la droite n'aura été aussi
loin dans la réflexion jamais un parti
politique comme les républicains issus
vous le savez de une longue histoire
jamais un parti politique à un an d'un
scrutin majeur aura été aussi prêt dans
sa tête sur ce qu'il veut faire et
comment il veut construire l'alternance
et ça c'est une base de crédibilité
absolument considérable alors évidemment
ce qu'on dit on le fera pour une bonne
raison que nous disons des choses
difficiles nous ne faisons pas que des
cadeaux français ça souvent été le cas
on prend les trente dernières années de
la vie politique
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de cadeaux qui
étaient effet c'est assez simple de dire
bonne nouvelle je vais t'offrir un
cadeau c'est plus compliqué de dire il
va falloir ensemble qu'on réforme notre
pays
ensemble pas les uns contre les autres
on réforme pas les uns contre les autres
on réforme les uns avec les autres et
donc il faut expliquer pourquoi il faut
expliquer quels résultats en attend il
faut expliquer l'impact qu'on attend il
faut que le changement ils soient
visibles et pas toujours ce changement
invisible d'un homme ou d'une femme
politique qui viennent une tribu qui
vous disent on va faire ça et puis deux
mois trois mois six mois un an après
alors qu'il est ministre ou président de
la république au premier ministre il
s'est rien passé
les français ne voient aucun changement
entre le discours et la réalité vécue
sur le terrain
donc il faut des changements visibles et
il faut des changements qui peut-être
peuvent
orthez de temps en temps est français
mais qui doivent être placés avec un
seul objectif qui est celui de l'intérêt
général et le redressement du pays quand
vous dites quand nous disons et quand
nicolas sarkozy dit qu'il faut que les
indemnisations que l'indemnisation du
chômage soit dégressive
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile l'idée
ce n'est pas de stigmatiser les
personnes qui recherchent un emploi tout
le monde à un moment donné se trouvent
dans cette situation il faut surtout
faire en sorte de dire moi ce que je
veux c'est combattre le chômage c'est
pas toujours défendre la société dans
lesquelles il ya ceux qui ont un emploi
et puis de laisser tomber tous ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas c'est pas de considérer
que la france elle a délibérément choisi
le chômage la france et l'a pas choisi
le chômage au fond dans l'air la réalité
elle la choisit dans ses politiques dont
il faut transformer ces politiques pour
indiquer que la france elle ne peut pas
accepter qui est une sorte de chômage
sorte de fatalité sur le chômage
aujourd'hui et l'indemnisation ou la
réduction ou la dégressivité de
l'indemnisation du chômage
elle participe à cette société qui dira
un moment donné qui lance un signal pour
dire il faut évidemment tout faire pour
que en remettent les personnes au
travail et il faut les inciter à cela ça
veut pas dire que uniquement ceci permet
de revenir sur le marché du travail
ça veut dire que à côté d'autres mesures
les choses deviennent cohérente
d'autres mesures c'est créer un vrai
marché du travail
madame elle que marié avec sa loi dont
elle dit tout le temps je faisais
remarquer à l'assemblée a dit tout le
temps ma loi un seul avait elle dit
ma loi et elle est toujours une loi de
retard parce que comme elle est décidée
à matino l'est pas toujours au courant
elle a pas reçues les les notes qu'il
lui dise ce qu'il faut qu'elle dise donc
c'est toujours ma loi malouas ma loi oui
mais c'est sa loi elle ressemble plus du
tout à ce qu'elle était à l'origine nous
avions nous avions d'ailleurs nous nous
les républiques on avait dit qu'on était
prêt à la voter
ça veut quand même dire que franchement
quand on nous dit la droite et la gauche
sur un gars enfin c'est c'est ringard de
dire que c'est ringard
et vous alors on dit c'est ringard de
dire il ya une démocratie dans une
démocratie une majorité et une
opposition alors que vous aviez dit que
vous appelez ça à droite ou
le nord ou sud vert ou bleu enfin vous
pouvez l'appeler comme vous voulez vous
lui donnez les donc vous voulez mais
dans les démocraties et bien des blocs
qui s'opposent parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
même vision et au travers de cette
opposition n'est la liberté d'expression
et la liberté de choix
il n'y a pas une sorte de magma une
confusion générale des sentiments au
profit à ce moment là uniquement de ceux
qui manipulent cela donc il faut
respecter la démocratie mais à bonn à
certains moments on se met d'accord et
c'est bien le cas
nous l'avons fait sur nous avions eu
l'intention de voter la loi de madame l
qu'aubry on le fera pas parce que c'est
plus la loi de madame elle comment il
c'est une autre loi passée par
évidemment pertes et profits avec la
panique à bord du gouvernement devant
les manifestations il ya encore des
manifestations aujourd'hui
enfin vous l'avez noté ça n'en finit pas
il ya ya voilà toutes les forces au fond
d'opposition se réunissent
la france souffre dieu dada mal c'est
que les contre-pouvoirs sont plus
importants que les pouvoirs et quand on
democracy le contre-pouvoir les
contre-pouvoirs sont plus importants que
les pouvoirs mais ça crée un immobilisme
absolument fort
voilà
voilà donc je vous disais je vous disais
qu'il ya un vrai mal français c'est que
les contre pouvoirs sont plus importants
que les pouvoirs est donc là la volonté
la capacité l'expression systématique
d'un refus de changement est une maladie
que nous devrons guérir et la seule
façon de la guerre c'est d'être clair
dans sa tête c'est d'exprimer ce que
nous souhaitons faire ce que nous
voulons faire ce que nous pouvons faire
ça ne sert à rien de faire rêver sur
quelque chose qui ne sera pas fait ça
sert de façon très très important de
projeter de donner une envie nouvelle
sur une france que nous devrons
redresser du bas jusqu'en haut et la
remettre dans le bon sens c'est
finalement probablement la meilleure des
idées qu'on puisse trouver c'est de
retrouver le chemin du bon sens alors
que nous avons perdu un peu partout ce
chemin là alors le président nicolas
sarkozy a remis à remy l'ump puis
maintenant les républicains dans le bon
sens on était véritablement la tête à
l'envers
ça a été un gros travail ça a été un
travail d'équipé était un gros travail
aujourd'hui c'est le cas vous êtes là
pour le montrer pour le le prouver et je
vais sans je vais tout de suite lui
passer la parole parce que je me sens
bouillir d'impatience
donc nous allons nicholas tatouages